Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
(Alkış)
Eğer kağıt kaleminiz hazırsa,
ışın kılıcı nasıl yapılıyor anlatacağım.
Ama o herkesi kesmeyebilir,
görünmezlik pelerinini de anlatayım dedim.
Eğer o da kesmezse,
ışınlanmayı da anlatayım, öyle bitirelim.
Hepsi beraber olsun,
bir paket halinde öğrenelim.
Tabii o kadar kolay değil,
onu yapmamız için önce
sormamız gereken bir iki şey var, örneğin;
bilim toplumda,
konu pazarlık ya nasıl geleceğim ben
bilim insanı olarak pazarlığa,
neyle pazarlık yapacağım,
diye sormamız gerek.
Umarım bu yardımcı olur.
Bilim toplum içinde nerede yer alıyor
ve bilim toplumla nasıl iletişiyor,
nasıl diyalog kuruyor, belki nasıl
pazarlık ediyor diye bir soru soracaksak,
zannediyorum çoğunuz, şu şemaya okay der,
yani sıkıntı yok.
Nedir, işte bir takım klişe laflar var;
şey var, işte efendim nedir;
bilim elli yıl sonrasının
teknolojisini kurar,
teknoloji de toplumla
sürekli iletişim halindedir,
kısa süreçlidir bu iletişim.
Teknoloji bir şey sunar,
toplum beğenir/ beğenmez.
Onun başarı göstergeleri, çok kısa
süreli başarı göstergeleri vardır.
Ona göre teknoloji yeni bir şey yapar.
Veya teknoloji değil de, toplum bir şey
ister; bellidir artık bunun böyle bir şey
istediği.
Olasılığı varsa, fırsatı varsa
teknoloji onu sunar.
Ama böyle hızlı hızlı, gider gelir;
bilim böyle daha arka plandadır.
Hani hep diyoruz ya,
keşke toplum bilimle çok haşır neşir
olsa, bilim topluma çok daha fazla ulaşsa.
Onda doğruluk payı var, yani
bilimden uzaklaşmak iyi bir şey değil.
Ama,
o başarı kriterlerini, başarı
göstergelerini kısa süreçli halleriyle
bilim uygulamak çok doğru değil,
yani burada aslında bilimin biraz
bir kol mesafesinde
kalmasında aslında yarar var.
Bilim uzun sürece dayalı bir şeydir.
Bizim çok yanılmamız gerek,
çok hatalar yapmamız gerek ki,
doğru şeyleri bulalım; nedir, doğru
soruları, doğaya evrene sorabileceğimiz
doğru soruları ve onu da
nasıl doğanın bize verdiği cevapları
dinleyebileceğimizi bulalım.
Bu uzun süreçli bir şey.
Ve buna örnek olarak
biraz müzikten verebilirim.
Hepimiz müzik dinliyoruz değil mi?
''Ben müzik dinlemiyorum,''
diyen olmaz herhalde.
Ama kaçınız avangart caz dinliyor
dediğim zaman, sessizlik olur.
Değil mi?
Neden, çünkü çoğunlukla
popüler müziği dinliyoruz
ve çok kısa sürede karar veriyoruz
başarılı albüm, kötü albüm, olmadı,
öbürü sattı ama ikinci
flop oldu falan filan diye.
Arka planda avangart caz çok dener, çok
yanılır, bazı şeyleri tutturamaz,
tekrar dener, bir şeyler olur.
O, zaman içinde popüler kültüre yansır
ve devam eder.
Şimdi bu örneği de verdiğim zaman
hem avangart cazcılar, hem bilim insanları
sanki böyle gidip oturuyorlar bir yere,
kendileri düşünüyorlar, ne yapabilirim.
Bugün ne olsun, deyip ofislerinde
oturuyorlar ve yeni bir fikir geliyor,
pat diye buradan bir ampül çıkıyor.
Gidip hemen 50 yıl ötesinin teknolojisini
yapıyoruz, ya da bazı ertesi gün gidiyoruz
salı böyle geçtiyse, çarşamba gidiyoruz,
oturuyoruz hadi bakalım diyoruz,
bekliyoruz, hiçbir şey yok.
Eve gidiyoruz bugün olmadı diye.
Tabii böyle olmuyor, öyle olsa ben gitmem
o ofise, yani böyle çekilir mi hayat.
Size göstermek istediğim aslında,
bilim insanlarının bildiği, biraz farkında
olduğu, özellikle benim alanım gibi
biraz, uçuk kaçık hani direkt
uygulaması olmayan alanlarda,
toplumun çok farkında olmadığı bir,
toplumdan aldığımız
bir input var, o da bu:
Bunu çok bilmiyor toplum,
belki de hani çok farkında değilsiniz ama,
sadece bilim kurgu ve halkın,
insanların sınır tanımazlık ve kesinlikle
doğa kurallarına uymasını beklemediği,
birtakım bilim kurgusal, fantezi şeylerini
biz aslında alıp
bir egzersizden geçiriyoruz.
Nedir bu egzersiz,
doğru soru ne?
Doğru soru derken,
işte örneklerini anlatacağım.
Hikâyeyi alıp bunu ben nasıl sorarsam,
bilim insanı olarak, asıl diyalog kurduğum
şey benim, doğa, evren.
Ona nasıl bir soru sorarsam benimle
konuşmaya başlar ve benimle iletişir.
Dolayısıyla bu egzersizi
yapmamız gerekiyor.
Doğru soru ne; buradan şeye geleceğiz,
ışın kılıcını ben nasıl yapacağım,
acaba doğru bir soru mu?
Zaten oradan başlamak gerekiyor,
bilim insanı olarak.
Peki pazarlık nereden geliyor,
hani tamam, bunu anladık.
Örnek olarak, işte doğru soruyu sorarak,
radyo astronomiyi kullanarak,
işte pulsarları, gezegenleri
falan öğrenebiliyorum;
aa orada yaşanacak yer varmış diyorum,
mesela gezegen olarak.
Efendim doğru soru sorarak, Higgs bozonu
hiçbir şekilde görmemiş olmamıza rağmen
aslında ondan dolayı oluşan diğer şeyleri;
işte çıkan ışık düzmelerini,
şuyu buyu falan görerek
demek ki başarmışız diyebiliyoruz,
o da aynen Ali Beyin dediği gibi bir ip.
Bunların hepsi genelde bip oluyor zaten,
çok fazla bir şey olmuyor
data sinyal olarak geldiği için bize.
Doğru soruyu sorup doğru
kanaldan onu öğrenmek gerek.
Pazarlık kısmı ne?
Ne diyececeğim yani ben yani,
bu yaşanmaz bir gezegenmiş,
yaşanır yap orayı mı diyeceğim?
Yani nasıl pazarlık edeceğim doğayla ben?
Nasıl ikna edeceğiz birbirimizi?
Başlangıç noktamızla değil de,
uyuşabildiğimiz başka bir
noktada buluşabilmek için.
Buna örnek olarak,
yine gözlem yoluyla çalışan sizin daha
haşır neşir olacağınız bir şey göstereyim.
Güneş'in rengi sarı, niye sarı?
Güneş'in içindeki elementlerin
çıkardığı ışık,
o dalga boyunda
biz onu görünce öğreniyoruz.
Doğru kanaldan bakınca,
doğru frekansa bakınca
Güneş'in içindeki elementleri öğreniyoruz.
Şarap kırmızı.
Kadehe koyduğunuzda kırmızı.
Biraz daha koyduğunuzda yine kırmızı,
çünkü içindeki pigmentler değişmiyor;
ışıkla etkileşince kırmızı olarak gözüken.
Ben şaraba başka bir renk ol diyemiyorum,
daha çok koyarak veya daha az koyarak.
İşte pazarlık burada geliyor.
Pazarlık bu.
Bu bir polimer; bunun bir rengi var,
ne olduğunun önemi bile yok.
Çünkü her renk olabiliyor.
Yeter ki çekiştirin,
doğru şekilde çekiştirin.
Doğada bu yok.
Yani bu polimer, bunu yapmıyor doğada.
Nasıl oluyor doğayla pazarlık.
İşte önce doğru soruyu buluyorsunuz,
nedir doğru soru?
Ne yapabilirim ki, senin,
madde olarak polimerin
ışıkla iletişimi, senin kendi pigmentine
ve kendi özelliklerine bağlı olmasın,
başka bir şeye bağlı olsun,
neye bağlı olsun, orada çekiştiriyoruz.
O zaman, şekline bağlı olsun,
boyutuna bağlı olsun.
Bu Cambridge Üniversitesinde
beraber çalıştığımız bir hocanın
lab'ında yapılmış bir ürün.
İşin esprisi de bu: doğru soru ne,
bir şeyin rengi nereden geliyor,
o rengi veren şey ne?
Dalga, yani ışık zaten elektromanyetik
dalga ise o elektromanyetik dalganın
özelliği rengini
belli eden özelliği dalga boyu.
Eğer böyle tek parça bir polimer,
yastık gibi bir polimer almak yerine
onu dalga boyuyla eş derecede
olacak şekilde bir düzen yaparsanız,
bunu biz yapıyoruz yani, biz laboratuvara
girip normalde tamamen polimerken
bunu bu şekilde organize bir hale
getirebiliyorsanız, o zaman artık
polimerin kendisi değil,
şekli ışıkla etkileşiyor.
Dolayısıyla o renkleri veriyor bize.
Ne işe yarar derseniz,
şey olarak da göstereyim,
hani nasıl rengi çekiştirince değişiyor,
işte o kilit nokta, o aradaki mesafe
değiştiği için başka renklerle iletişiyor.
Polimer esnek.
Nerede kullanabiliriz?
Paris moda şovunda kullanıldı bu.
İşte burada doğayla pazarlık,
doğanın bize vermediği bir şeyi
doğayla konuşarak ve fizik kurallarına
veya bilim kuralları içerisinde kalarak
ama doğanın doğal olarak sunmadığı
bir şeyi elde etme olarak
tanımlayabiliyorum pazarlığı.
Peki.
Işın kılıcı dedik nereye geldik.
Bilim kurgudan yola çıktığımız için
isterseniz onu sonraya bırakalım,
böyle en hani cezbeden, en böyle hani
fantastik bir şey dediğimiz ışınlanma var.
Şöyle.
Ne yapıyorsunuz,
Captain Kirk Star Trek'den bildiğimiz adam
her gittiği gezegende olay çıkarıyor.
Onu gemiye geri getirmemiz gerekiyor,
adam diplomasiyi bilmediği için,
nereye gitsek, aman beni kurtarın,
hop hemen ışınlıyoruz,
uzay gemisine geri geliyor.
Nedir esprisi bunun?
İşte burada olduğu gibi,
böyle bir yere geliyorsunuz,
bu maddeyi buradan alıyoruz,
başka bir yere atıyoruz.
Işık hızından hızlı bir şekilde böyle,
anlık bir anda başka bir yerde beliriyor.
Eğer siz bana gelip de bilim kurgu
olarak bunu sorduğunuzda,
hadi abi bunu yap dediğinizde,
ben gidip de ilk önce şu şekille başlarsam
yapmaya, insan girsin bir önce diye
başlarsam yanlış soru sormuş oluyorum.
Çünkü benim sormam
gereken başka bir şey var.
Işınlanma nedir ki, demem gerekiyor önce.
Neyin ışınlanması bir kere, illa el kol mu
olmak zorunda, başka bir oluru yok mu?
Çünkü görüyoruz ki, fizik kuralları içinde
ışınlanma şu an mümkün gözükmüyor.
İşte bilim insanının yaptığı,
o egzersiz dediğim doğru soruyu bulmak
ve o soruyuyla,
doğayla o soru aracılığıyla pazarlık
kurmak dediğim ilk örnek bu.
Işınlanma bu şekilde olmuyor ama
başka şekilde olabiliyor.
Bu bilimsel bir makale.
Physical Review Letters,
bayağı tanınan bilinen bir dergi.
Ve bu altı insan, bilim insanı
bir araya geliyor ve diyor ki,
ya ışınlanmayı biz hani Selami Bey'in
buradan Kadıköy'e ışınlanması olarak
değil de, başka bir çerçevede ele alırsak
ne olabilir, diye sorunca
şeyi fark ediyorlar.
Kuantum mekaniğinin enteresan bir özelliği
var, dolanıklık dediğimiz bir özellik bu.
İki tane obje eğer birbiriyle iletişmişse
ve bunu ayırdığınızda, aradaki o ilintiyi
bozmadan ayırırsanız, buna
yaptığınız bir şey öbürünü etkiliyor.
Çünkü aslında bu tek bir şey,
tek bir obje gibi davranıyor.
Bunu kullanarak, anlatmayacağım detayını,
bunu kullanarak bilgiyi, maddeyi değil
ama bilgiyi teleport etme yani ışınlama
olabileceğini iddia ediyorlar, 1993.
Şimdi bunu yaptığınız zaman, diyorsunuz ki
tabii bir sürü deli makale var, yani
her biri de olacak diye bir şey yok.
97-98 arasında üç ayrı
laboratuvarda bu gösteriliyor.
Deneysel olarak gösteriliyor.
Işık kullanılarak,
bunun ölçümlerini yaparak,
bilginin bir noktadan başka bir noktaya
anlık transferi
olduğunu gösterebiliyorlar.
Düşünsenize şu,
1998 daha alan biraz gençken bu kuantum,
bilgisayar konseptlerinin olduğu alan,
kuantum teknoloji alanı biraz gençken,
bu kadarcık bir konferans grubu var
ve bu konferans grubunun
şu oklarla gösterdiklerim,
teorisini öne kuranlar, öne sunanlar
ve deneyini yapanlar hep beraberler.
İşte 98 yılında, inanılmaz
derecede ateşli bir tartışma
ve diyalog geçti, konu ışınlanmaydı.
Ve ben de doktora birinci sınıf
öğrencisi olarak, bunlara tanık oldum
ve bu alanı nasıl bırakırım
bu deneyimden sonra tabii ki.
Yetmedi, kesmedi ikinciye
hemen hızlıca geçiyorum.
Aranızda şey diyenler olabilir, vay be
kuantum işi çözmüş, ışınlanma yapıldı.
Birçoğunuz da şey diyebilir,
hocam ben sana bakırdan boru versem,
onu ışınlayamadığın sürece
ben yemem bu numarayı.
Tamam, doğru.
Işınlayamıyorum, onu kabul edeyim.
Ama görünmez yapabilirim, istiyorsanız
görünmezlik pelerini atayım üzerine.
Görünmez olsun.
Nasıl doğru soru sormam gerekiyor doğaya,
bana bir şeyi görünmez yapması için,
demem gerekiyor işte bilim insanı olarak.
Bunu soran oldu, bunu soran
John Pedry Londra'da.
Ve dedi ki,
bakırı yani o pelerinli kumaşı
acaba nedir, doğru bir soru değil.
Doğru soru;
ben sizi zaten niye görüyorum ki?
Niye görüyorum ben sizi?
Çünkü sizden ışık yansıyor bana.
Elektromanyetik dalgalar sizden sekip
bana geliyor, benim gözlerime.
Ben algılıyorum sizi.
Araya bir şey koyduğunuz
zaman sizi görmeyeceğim.
Aynı sizi gördüğüm için
arkadakini görmediğim gibi.
Veya aynı şu an spotlight
olduğu için sizi görmediğim gibi.
O zaman ne yapıyoruz?
Öyle bir şey yapalım ki,
aramıza bir şey koyarsak,
mesela bakırdan boru diyelim,
onu koyarsak elektromanyetik
dalgalar, ışık etrafımızda,
o bakır borunun
etrafından dönsün ve geçsin.
Aynı aerodinamik bir arabanın üzerinden
havanın akıp türbülans yaratmadan
arka tarafa geçtiği gibi.
Tabii, deli saçması bir şey
diyebilirsiniz ama adam yazmış.
2016 yılında bunu öneriyor
matematiksel olarak.
Ve doğru soru sorduğu için
doğru bir cevap da bulabiliyor.
Öyle bir şey olsun ki
o görünmezlik pelerini,
açısına göre bazı özellikleri değişsin.
İşte kırınım indeksi falan değişsin,
bir şeyler olsun.
O zaman ışık bile aynı havanın yaptığı
gibi böyle etrafından güzelce dolanarak
geçsin gitsin.
Bunu önerdi 2016 yılında.
Çok beklemeye gerek olmadı,
görüyorsunuz cilt 312,
iki cilt sonra aynı yılda hemen
yapıldı bunun deneyi ve gösterildi.
Böyle bir şey yaptılar.
Bu bayağı büyük bir
cihaz santim boyutunda.
Ve mikrodalga frekansı işte bu pazarlık,
hani bizim gördüğümüz şekilde değil de,
bir frekansta veya bir frekans diliminde
görünmez hâle getirme olayı.
Doğa bize hepsini vermiyor,
al sana pelerin demiyor ama,
al sana pelerin şu frekansta diyor.
Peki bu deneyde neyi görünmez
kıldılar, deney olarak yaptılar?
10 santimlik bakırdan bir boru.
O görünmez oldu.
Şimdi artık optik kısmını da yapabiliyoruz
devam ediyor bu invisibility cloak'lar.
Tatmin olduysanız bırakayım,
yoksa ışın kılıcına geçeyim mi?
Geçeyim değil mi?
Tamam, ışın kılıcı yapacağız,
nasıl yapacağız?
Işın kılıcı için yine aynı soruyu sormamız
gerekiyor, bu hani biraz pratik yaptık,
egzersiz gibi oldu.
Aynı soruları sormamız gerekiyor.
Işın kılıcı nasıl
yapacağımız sorusu yerine,
doğru soru ne, diye sormamız gerekiyor.
Çünkü gidip de oturup ışın kılıcı
yapmaya çalışırsam olmaz.
Işın kılıcının özelliklerini sayalım.
Nedir, bir kere çok çok güçlü olacak ki
duvarı demiri falan böyle kessin.
Savurduğunda yıksın atsın.
Bu zaten var, lazer olacak demek ki.
Lazer zaten kuantum bir obje,
demek ki kuantum mekaniğini getireceğiz
bir şekilde ona hazır olun,
bakırdan boru bitti.
Kesebiliyorsa çok güçlü bir lazer olacak,
var elimizde zaten yapıyoruz.
Yani birçok manufacturing dediğimiz şey
aslında lazer teknolojisi kullanıyor.
İki; sesi var, ışın sesi gürültüsü
onu yaptık tamam o, o var.
Ama şeydeki gibi, Star Wars'daki
gibi bir ses çıkarmasını istiyorsanız,
o topraklama hatası, o da kolay.
Aranızdaki elektrisyenler her Star Wars
seyrettiğinde rahatsız olmuştur zaten
o raovv duyduğunda
bağlayın şunu toprağa, diye.
(Kahkaha)
Bu arada deney gerçekten öyle yani
televizyona takılmamış anteni,
televizyon önüne sallayarak
o ses kaydedilmiştir bu arada.
Yani ışınla falan alakası yok o sesin.
Üçüncüsü işte asıl
bilim insanı için önemli olan.
Yahu, iki tane ışık hüzmesi var,
böyle gelecekler,
biri öbürünü durduracak.
Ama elimizde şeylerle,
el fenerleriyle çok oynadık.
Hiç durdurmuyor,
yani ışık ışığı görmüyor aslında.
Yani bir ışık, aynı yerde başka bir
ışık hüzmesi olduğunun farkında olmuyor.
Zaten fiziksel olarak, olay bu.
O zaman ne yapmamız gerekiyor?
Işığın birbiriyle etkileşmesini,
iki ışık hüzmesinin birbirinin
farkındalığını yaratmamız gerekiyor.
Bunu sordular, bunu da sordular.
Şu olayı, şu iki insan sordu.
Harvard'dan MIT'den 2 tane ünlü profesör.
Bunu sordu ve şöyle karar verdiler:
ya aslında hikmet ışıkta değil,
hikmet o ışığın bulunduğu gaz ortamında.
Hani konserlerde buradan gaz veriyoruz ya,
yani eğer ışın kılıcı oynayacaksak,
o gazın olması gerekiyor.
İçinde bulunduğumuz
bir medyumun olması gerekiyor.
O medyumu doğru seçerseniz,
doğru ne demek;
çok büyük bir gaz bulutu
bulmanız gerekiyor.
Bu gaz bulutunun içine
ışık hüzmelerini koymamız gerekiyor.
Ama o gaz bulutu öyle
sıradan bir gaz bulutu değil.
Evrenin en soğuk, en ücra köşesindeki
derecenin ısıran bir ısının,
bir milyarda biri kadar soğutuluyor.
Çok soğuk, küçük bir gaz bulutu.
İçinde olmanız gerektiği için,
çok küçük bir şey olmanız gerekiyor.
Şurada da deneyini göstereyim.
Çok küçük bir mini insan olursanız,
bu gaz bulutunun içine girersiniz.
Gaz bulutu şurası,
bu gaz bulutunu tutmak için
şöyle bir laboratuvar kurmak gerekiyor.
Aynı zamanda üç yerden, üç değişik
yönden toplam altı tane lazerin sürekli
size müdahale etmesi gerekiyor
orada tutmak için o gazı.
Her şeyi yaptığınızda, sadede geliyorum,
iki tane ışık hüzmesi o ortamın içinde
atomların rezonanslarını da kullanarak
bir araya geldiğinde fark ediyorlar
birbirini,ilk defa dünyada.
O iki ışık hüzmesi,
artık birbiriyle iletişime başlıyor.
Ve işte işin sürprizi bu.
Ne buluyorlar biliyor musunuz,
iki ışık hüzmesi birbirini bulunca,
mıknatıs gibi yapışıyorlar.
Hani hiç öyle birbirini geçmeme gibi,
yani kılıç savaşı yapacak şekilde değil,
tam tersine kılıçlar dokunur dokunmaz
yapışıyorlar birbirlerine,
atıyorsunuz artık.
Yapacak tek şey oturup
(Kahkaha)
geriye yapacak tek şey kalıyor,
o da diyalog ve pazarlık.
Sohbet etmeniz gerekiyor,
böyle çözmeniz gerekiyor olayları.
Diyeceğim bu, ışın kılıcı buydu.
Yapan da oldu, bu makaleyi
okursanız detaylarını öğrenirsiniz,
yemek yapma şeyi gibi.
Daha fazla şeye gerek yok,
ama tek söyleyeceğim
umarım üç tane örnekle
şu fikri vermişimdir;
hep bilimden yola çıkarak teknolojiye
veya topluma gidilir diye anlıyoruz,
aslında çok önemli, gerçekten bizim için
çok önemli başka bir kanal daha var:
toplumun sınır tanımaz yaratıcılığı.
Bize her zaman ilham oluyor,
dolayısıyla hem bilimle haşır neşir olun,
hem bilime dönün yüzünüzü,
bilimi hayatınızdan eksik etmeyin,
ama bilimle sınırlamayın kendinizi,
lütfen o yaratıcılığınızı aşın devam edin,
biz onun doğayla pazarlığını
yapmasını biliyoruz.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)